welcome to this video playing yeah he
empty up from Norway heligan or down
okay don't think I've played him know
and I haven't played it before so let's
see you goon felt or Kings Indian okay
so let's see what lies i can i wanted to
actually try out the our buck again
that's a pretty good line actually it's
not played so often but it has some some
interesting ideas now it's a key
decision for black you're going to play
for a 504 c 5 okay black can also do
something like see 6a 6b five but
normally e5 or c5 it is you cannot play
a five right away as i can capture take
on d eight and so on yeah this is
another possibility going for a benoni i
used to earn played d take c5 here but
it turned out that d takes d5 the
recapture is ok for black okay so i'll
advance now aged six is normally played
after which it is an important decision
where to put the bishop in fact their
Bishop f4 is the Maine moose yeah this
is also possible now I'm glad to have
Queen d2 end so that h6 is not going to
be played after it takes d5 white takes
he takes d5 just keeping a symmetrical
type of porn structure at least well
that's not totally symmetrical but form
on the queenside and
three on the queenside for both with an
open e-file this is a very young yeah
it's a bit of an old-fashioned line
black normally plays a 6cm not necessary
but a six a 48 or rookie aid immediately
okay interesting 94 is probably the idea
yeah but ok this loses lots of time or
is there something great that I can do
yeah I guess I guess not at least not
worth spending ages on it the ID for 94
Queenie for castles I mean this should
be it should be a slight edge for white
anyway the Queen will definitely move
again after some something like Age 3
Bishop d3 or Bishop d3 immediately the
abbey should be three immediately
actually Queen g4s just not a great
place for the Queen interesting thing is
after Bishop d3 you cannot go back to e8
rook rook e1 it's terrible after that so
he really wants to go to g4 yeah Jeff
just the name right okay so I'll do that
Queen g4 and then rookie one intending
rookie form this looks like a good line
yeah I thought this wasn't playable
really like totally not playable rookie
1b should be 7 mm maybe Queenie fries
the Sun some sort of
yeah but that's not really really great
is it I'm wondering which look I should
take rook rook a to you one does have
some point as Queen a 4 has probably
happened then it's going to happen that
and then i have b 3 without hanging my
rook yeah I came but Queenie fine what
is it actually doing I think I can still
play just be should be seven and when
they'll probably win they exchanged rook
e8 Bishop t6 is also terrible hmm or is
there something better I mean this
should be having this really good but
move like Bishop age six is also quite
good really funny yeah I wonder yeah but
let's grab this i mean it's its material
okay so should i take the porn or the
rook that's that's in fact an
interesting decision
now taking the pawn has some merited it
it allows 95 or Bishop b5 after that
yeah I prefer that really the deep one
is also very strong so it I'm not one
hundred percent sure about this but it
was it was a certainly a valid
alternative to poon to grab d6 yeah i
was expecting looky aid because now I'm
neutralizing this Bishop here and if
that happens black really is out of
active pieces night on a 68 can jump to
before but after a three just in
exchange against this at the moment not
so good bishop came so b3 simply that's
Quinn before that's not great okay maybe
just here if he takes it straightened my
pawn structure
Queen B form maybe yeah but I can I can
answer that with Quincy to if everything
else fails just an odd Queenie to Queen
each was probably even better yeah yeah
I thought just just a 3m getting getting
this traded and it wasn't really
attacking it ya know that I think of it
with because of the pin okay I can play
rookie six now it should be nice yeah if
i go here probably needs to take yeah
that they cannot ever get to the to the
poor now king of eight queen shade is
funny okay okay time money can do this
first check check yeah
Jeff oh you can just take oh I forgot
about that I totally forgot about that
ah no really
how stupid can you be really now I think
it's probably it's probably still
winning maybe it's it's still winning
but this was of course totally idiotic
what I did hey I thought it simply
forgot my things and let me tell
exchange queens gian it was Queenie five
looks totally normal but it is a bad
move really if i play a four I think
then then it's just over here probably
Queenie five coming now is something
even more precise or King f1 maybe I
just avoid the checks just avoid the
checks and then get to e5 like he only
has a somewhat meaningless waiting move
that you can play in an hour v6 or
something and then I'm putting it here
and the Queen can net cannot move with
the check so whenever the Queen moves I
[ __ ] seven and here it was just just
just totally stupid she allowing the
allowing the check check yeah and him
but wait let's just let's just think
about it is it ok you must give the
check now and okay I need to do that and
then probably this is this should be it
is it's a draw it's a draw I here I can
play a seven
surely this is going to win yeah this is
winning i get to e5 the shooters this is
too active really ok i played this on
really a bad end game here and he
probably should play age 6 I thought II
7 but the g5 is just just coming and
this is a draw yeah this bliss was a bad
game I mean really and the question is
though is this a win
yeah the thing is this is what we got
let me think about it here ok we can we
now did this
hmm ma'am maybe not sure what is most
precise about it probably should not
matter that much ok this is this is of
course not the toughest defense but it's
clear that that this is possible and I
win the F porn so I'm a porn up but it's
this really relevant I mean he's got the
outside passer I cannot go over here
because of the porn so I probably yeah
this is probably even good for black
it's not really measuring it's not
really measuring that I have two pawns
yeah something like that black is
winning and he will push this and at the
end we'll get to the Queen side so this
is not really good I need to go here or
something check yeah that's probably
really a draw ok so maybe maybe here i
can do i can improve somehow this this
maybe it does not i was thinking about
this if you look at this position for
example then this porn is actually it's
not protected him so if you if you look
at the same thing that we had before
something like this i can actually go
over all the way
but am what I really don't get at the
moment that the computer gives this as a
win but this is a draw how is this
drawing page six okay yeah it's clear
that i cannot just just go over as the h
pawn is too quick but what is the
difference i don't i don't understand
the difference at the moment why this is
any worse King g5 if he goes check it is
this now
even here are then I push the f corn Wow
yeah King important games are
notoriously tricky ok so I have wondered
on that the start of all this what about
this is it is it some city somehow
relevant to not play a form if I start
like that let's say this is this may be
interesting if he takes let's briefly
look about look at that probably a six
cell is six
interestingly enough this this should
win wow yeah that's very tricky I mean
okay it wasn't it was necessary at all
to allow it but but very very
complicated key opponent game here funny
okay I need to end the video at some
point okay well thanks for watching